il a disparu en 2000 mais il pourrait
faire son grand retour le septennat
présidentiel Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel
Macron ils sont favorables pourtant sous
la Cinquième République le septennat
était plusieurs fois remis en question
1973 le président Georges Pompidou veut
le raccourcir je pense que il fallait
consulter le pays un peu plus souvent et
j'ai pensé que une durée de 5 ans était
bonne avec ce quinquennat le président a
deux ambitions renforcer la légitimité
du chef de l'État auprès des français
mais aussi éviter les cohabitations un
projet de loi constitutionnel et voté
par les deux assemblées puis finalement
ajournée le quinquennat définitivement
enterré non car il revient sur la table
en 1987 Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
l'ancien président milite lui aussi pour
réduire le mandat présidentiel
tous ceux qui ont étudié le problème
audit c'est trop long et moi qui l'ai
vécu je vous dis c'est trop long
même le président François Mitterrand if
favorable c'était en 1994 alors qu'au
début de sa présidence il plaidait
plutôt pour un septennat non
renouvelable je maintiens que si une
nette majorité dans des deux assemblées
et en même temps qu'une majorité des
formations politiques faut pas que ce
soit simplement un parti politique
majorité 100 ans sur le quinquennat
passé de 7 à 5 j'ai mis opposerai pas le
débat s'invite aussi dans la campagne
présidentielle de 1995 et le sujet
divise le candidat RPR Jacques Chirac et
contre Lionel Jospin le candidat
socialiste et pour et il en profite pour
tacler son rival avec cette réplique
devenue célèbre en somme je vous redis
non bien sûr mais avec un fond de
sérieux qui vaut mieux cinq ans avec
Jospin que 7 ans avec Jacques Chirac
les années passent et toujours pas de
quinquennat à l'horizon en 2000 il
refait surface avec un projet de loi
constitutionnel à la manœuvre Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing alors député UD il
était difficile de le faire plus tôt car
on soulevait
car en soulevait alors l'héritante
question de savoir si le président de la
République devait se l'appliquer à
lui-même la gauche mais aussi une partie
de la droite rejoignent l'ancien chef de
l'État et le président Jacques Chirac
d'abord c'est toujours non mais
finalement c'est oui le 6 juillet 2000
il annonce aux Français la tenue d'un
référendum en prenant la parole plus
fréquemment vous serez mieux à même
d'exprimer notre ambition et de choisir
les grandes orientations que vous voulez
pour notre pays le 24 septembre 2000 le
will emporte à plus de
73%. la durée du mandat présidentiel
passe de 7 à 5 ans d'abord sans
limitation du nombre de mandats puis en
2008 il sera limité à deux quinquennat
consécutifs
[Musique]